pues más de la mitad de este
dinero se irá para renovar y reimpulsar
proyectos de infraestructura que ya
estaban en marcha en el país pero le doy
un desglose más o menos 110 mil millones
irán para la construcción de carreteras
y puentes
65 mil millones para crear más internet
ofrecer más internet de banda ancha para
los estadounidenses se irán 25 mil
millones para renovar aeropuertos y
también 73 mil millones para ampliar la
red eléctrica esto es para que la red
eléctrica de eeuu pueda empezar a
transportar más energía renovable es sin
duda pues la inversión en
infraestructura más grande que se haya
hecho en la última década en eeuu sin
embargo no llega a los 23 billones de
dólares inicialmente propusieron los
demócratas para pues invertir en la
infraestructura de infraestructura que
muchos analistas dicen pues está en
estado crítico en eeuu hay que mencionar
también que el gobierno de eeuu se
endeudará en 256 mil millones de dólares
a pesar de que los demócratas decían que
pues gran parte de esta plata de esta
plata para el plan de infraestructura
saldría bien más impuestos para
multimillonarios cristóbal este plan fue
aprobado tras un acuerdo bipartidista
que hace falta ahora para que se
convierta en ley que sea firmado por el
presidente de bailén y que se empieza a
implementar
pues hace falta un paso muy importante y
es que la cámara de representantes lo
creó y después entonces el presidente lo
firme y se empiece a implementar sin
embargo lo que ha dicho los demócratas
en la cámara de representantes que
tienen mayoría tanto el ala progresista
como el ala moderada es que si no se
aprueba previamente en el senado el
presupuesto de 35 billones de dólares
para la política social pues que ellos
en la cámara representantes simplemente
no van a aprobar el plan de
infraestructura es decir están poniendo
un lucro si se aprueba el plan social el
plan presupuestal social con mayoría
simple en el senado ellos en la cámara
baja aprobaran el plan de
infraestructura así que pues va a ser
una semana definitivamente bastante
movida acá en washington porque estará
en debate entonces en el senado entre
los demócratas este gran plan desde
política social de 35 billones de
dólares para que se pueda probar
entonces definitivamente el plan de
infraestructura que muchísimas gracias a
por toda esta información